[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui est en direct
avec nous depuis shanghai est donc en
chine et c'est vous arnauld miguet
bonjour arnaud danjean pauline merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
correspondant de france télévisions en
chine arnaud shanghai est en guerre
contre le variant au micro nuque ovide
19 ça fait cinquante trois jours que des
mesures de confinement ont été mises en
place chez vous elles sont censées avoir
été allégé ces jours derniers qu'en est
il
alors allé j'ai peut-être mais en tout
cas pas partout moi je peux vous dire
que ça fait cinquante trois jours que
nous sommes dans mon quartier est
confiné et le confinement continue on
appelle même sa une période de silence
c'est à dire qu'avec le confinement et à
l'intérieur du confinement ont reconquis
encore plus alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
certains quartiers où les gens peuvent
sortir avec une autorisation spéciale
ils peuvent aller faire des courses par
exemple au supermarché mais là encore il
faut une invitation du supermarché pour
qu'ils puissent y entrer et c'est une
sortie une personne par foyer et tous
les deux jours seulement donc de
déconfinement non il ya toujours un
confinement strict à shanghai en tout
cas strictes aux yeux du monde puisque
même en france lorsque vous avez connu
le confinement ça n'était évidemment pas
aussi strictes qui sillonnent 53 jours
donc ça fait presque deux mois raconté
nous à quoi ont ressemblé à la fois pour
vous est peut-être pour les habitants de
votre quartier c'est ces deux derniers
mois votre quotidien
écoutez le quotidien s'était d'abord
dans un premier temps de trouver à
manger de pouvoir se faire livrer de la
nourriture dont j'ai de la chance on à
être nourris mais certains quasiment pas
été nourris pendant 50 jours et devait
compter sur l'aide du gouvernement pour
que le gouvernement leur apportent de la
nourriture et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
arrivées de temps en temps de carton
avec du chou de la sonal du port en
boîte qui est distribué par les
autorités locales voire les autorités
nationales voire les voir les autres
provinces de chine qui font des dons
donc ça c'était la course à la
nourriture dans un premier temps et il
vient des quartiers où ils étaient très
très difficile d'avoir de
l'approvisionnement et les gens
véritablement en ont souffert avec la
faim au ventre et puis ensuite le
confinement ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
fasse rien puisqu'il y avait des tests
et il ya toujours des tests pcr
régulièrement dans la ville vous n'êtes
pas tranquille en confinement les gens
viennent tambouriner à votre porte
parfois à 7 heures du matin sans préavis
pour que vous alliez vous faire tester
et puis dans mon cas évidemment j'avais
la possibilité j'ai toujours eu la
possibilité de pouvoir sortir de ma
résidence et de voir ce qui se passait
dans cette ville sans tourner dans cette
ville morte où il ne se passe
strictement rien mais c'est toujours un
spectacle étonnant mais ville fantôme
arnaud ça vous connaît ceux qui ne sont
pas familiers de votre parcours il me
faut vous rappeler rappeler que vous
avez déjà été confinée pendant plus de
trois mois au printemps 2000 vingt sept
et à lujan épicentre de l'épidémie
mondiale de kovy vous étiez alors le
seul journaliste sur place vous avez
donc en la matière une certaine
expérience à la fois personnelle et
professionnelle
oui c'est vrai alors c'est très
différent ce confinement de morale et ce
confinement de shanghai bien qu'il y ait
eu d'autres vie confinée en chine entre
couronne et shanghai et il ya aussi
d'autres villes confiné en chine en ce
moment même on considère qu'il ya à peu
près 190 millions de personnes qui
connaissent des confinement en chine et
c'est plus d'une vingtaine de villes
évidemment shanghai et là où les
projecteurs se braquent la différence
entre humour année shanghai haoran y
avait vraiment la peur de l'inconnu la
peur de ce virus qui n'avait à l'époque
pas encore de nom et qui était très
meurtrier aujourd'hui à shanghai la peur
qui tous les 25 millions d'habitants
c'est moins le virus qui est moins
mortelle que le la gestion des autorités
des gens peuvent être embarqués vers des
camps d'isolement il ya eu à peu près
deux millions de personnes à ce jour qui
ont été embarqués dans des camps de
quarantaine parce qu'ils étaient
positifs au premier distingue parce
qu'ils étaient quatre contacts ou même
négatif mais avec des cas positifs à
proximité etc qu'en guise allmand je
peux vous assurer que personne ne veut y
aller très souvent il n'ya pas de
douches des sanitaires à ces primaires
de la lumière allumée jour et nuit et
finalement il y a il ya très peu de
traits prendre on attend que ça passe
car comme vous le savez il n'y a pas de
remède miracle contre le comique 19 mai
on isole ça fait partie de la méthode
chinoise confinement et isolement on
isole la population touchée par le virus
et là c'est un petit peu la roulette
russe en chine vous avez des immeubles
entiers qui sont évacués et parfois manu
militari et des images souvent très
violente de gens qui sont embarqués vers
ces camps d'isolement où ils ne veulent
pas aller et au départ ou débuts ici à
shanghai les enfants étaient même
séparés de leurs parents vous avez un
enfant qui est testé positif les parents
qui ne le sont pas eh bien les enfants
étaient embarqués vers des camps
d'isolement la politique a quelque peu
changé des politiques ici à shanghai
beaucoup changé d'ailleurs ces
politiques sanitaires ce qui fait qu'on
n'en perd un petit peu le nord et c'est
ce qui effraie un petit peu la
population en plus du reste évidemment
en plus de l'isolément et angus de
l'enfermement qui est très stricte ici
puisque vous avez des gens ils sont
littéralement emmuré vous avez des gens
qui sont mis dans les cages et qui ne
peuvent véritablement pas mettre un pied
dehors pour moi ça fait cinquante trois
jours pour d'autres ça a commencé début
mars la chine arnaud a été l'un des
premiers pays à se débarrasser du coc
vide 19 quelques mois après l'apparition
de la maladie et bien il avait inscrit
avec fierté dans son discours dans son
récit national qu'est ce que la
résurgence de l'épidémie avec ses
variantes dit de la fragilité de ce
géant mondial
alors ça fait partie en effet du
discours national est ce que c'est c'est
ce que si j mme inga a rappelé nous
avons gagné la bataille de hauranne nous
gagnerons celle de shanghai avec
persévérance plus tu es dans le mot
persévérance puisque la persévérance il
faut en avoir pour tenir aussi longtemps
que croyez moi mais la chine avait servi
en quelque sorte d'exemple et avait
réussi à presque éradiquée au nom de la
politique zéro covi et le zéro est
important et c'est ce que tout le monde
veut atteindre ici puisque c'est la
volonté du père de cette politique le
président lui-même si gilles ging la
chine veut arriver à cela alors ça a
marché pendant deux ans et c'était avant
le variant omicron beaucoup plus
contagieux c'était aussi
avant les vaccins et là il se trouve que
la population chinoise n'est finalement
pas si bien vaccinés que cela on parle
de 90% de la population vaccinée mais en
fait les seniors les enfants les plus
vulnérables en d'autres termes le son
peut vacciner si bien que les décès que
vous avez en ce moment ici à shanghai il
ya eu encore un mort annoncé
officiellement aujourd'hui sont des
personnes âgées qui généralement n'ont
pas reçu les trois doses des vaccins
chinois puisque les chinois n'utilise
que leur médecin et donc il ya une
certaine fragilité mais en même temps
l'objectif a été fixé ce fameux objectif
de zéro co vie et on voit mal les
autorités centrales locales changer de
politique et changer leur fusil d'épaulé
sauf qu'il y à deux coups très
importants arnaud à cette politique zéro
covit d'abord un coût économique la
chine a des indicateurs qu'ils sont qui
n'ont jamais été aussi mauvais depuis
deux ans c'est le premier coup et le
second coup il n'est peut-être social on
a entendu beaucoup de critiques et
notamment à l'égard de celui qui incarne
cette politique le président xi jinping
bien sûr des critiques il y a et il y en
a tous les jours sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois très rapidement censuré je peux
vous dire que les censeurs ont beaucoup
beaucoup de travail en cependant vous
avez des images qui sont absolument
terrifiantes vous avez des images de
gens embarqués vers les camps
d'isolement vous avez des images de
suicide également puisqu'il ya des
suicides dans la ville vous avez des
images de et des témoignages de victimes
collatérales parce que finalement on a
l'impression qu'on peut mourir de tout
dans cette ville sens du comique 19 et
donc vous avez des gens qui sont dans
une france des gens qui ont des crises
cardiaques vous avez des gens qui ont
des cancers qui doivent être soignés
mais qui ne sont pas soignés parce que
toute la mobilisation se portent vers le
vide et vers le comique 19 et vers les
malades du comique 19 mais on ne voit
pas pour autant les autorités changer de
politique et d'ailleurs elle le martèle
la politique zéro co vide vous verrez
dans le long terme c'est nous qui avons
raison c'est nous qui avons eu
officiellement le moins deux morts
pendant toute cette pandémie qui dure
depuis plus de deux ans maintenant donc
les autorités martèle que c'est la seule
politique possible et ils ne changeront
pas et est ce que m les indicateurs
économiques pourraient faire déplacer ou
en tout cas je réorienter cette
politique zéro coved là pour le coup
bien sûr lille et vous avez raison les
le coût de cette politique zéro co vide
est absolument désastreux pour
l'économie la chine se ferment toujours
plus le prétexte est le 02 vide mais il
y à quelque chose d'autre qui se cache
derrière c'est probablement une volonté
politique de toutes façons cette
politique 0e vide est une politique donc
c'est un choix qui est assumé le
président xi jinping a toujours dit en
chine nous mettrons nous mettons l'être
humain avant l'économie et c'est au nom
de cela que les autorités chinoises ont
mis en place cette politique 08 mais on
sent le parti communiste n'est pas un
monolithe qui ne parle que d'une seule
voix il ya des dissensions même si la
voix du président si jim dine
l'emportent en ce moment et il ya
probablement des gens qui veulent ouvrir
et qui disent gare à l'économie vous
avez des entreprises qui sondage nous
vous avez évidemment des petits
commerces qui sont à genoux socialement
les gens à shanghai ne travaille pas et
donc perdre leur emploi vous avez les
exportations qui sont en diminution les
objectifs de croissance seront
évidemment pas respecter l'objectif
était de 5 5 % on en sera loin vous avez
la chine qui représentent la moitié des
ports du monde qui sont quasiment à
l'arrêt ou qui fonctionne à minima et
puis vous avez des expatriés la moitié
des français de chine serait parti n'en
pouvons plus de cette politique 0.8 donc
forcément c'est un désastre économique
et le président le premier ministre par
don chinois li keqiang a rappelé à
toutes les provinces à toutes les
municipalités de réinjecter de l'argent
dans l'économie en d'autres termes de
relance et une politique
d'investissements publics pour pallier
ce problème économique merci beaucoup
arnaud le journalisme est un sport de
combat en chine et on imagine
particulièrement en ce moment très bon
courage à vous et on vous retrouve bien
sûr sur les antennes de france
télévisions
bonne journée à shanghai non